if you want to see how ridiculous this
is and how the lies get laundered so we
started with AOC basically mocking the
entire hearing not being upset that
People's First Amendment rights were
infringed on again because if the
government which it sounds like it was
these FBI agents were pressuring
people's speech to be taken off Twitter
that is a violation of your respect she
doesn't care about that she she confuses
the issue related to the to the laptop
as if it is not real we know it is real
and it's all you know right-wing
conspiracy and everything else well how
does that sort of lie then get laundered
through the system well the way it does
is that when you turn on CNN tonight and
God bless you I know you're not going to
do it but if you have an NPC cousin who
watches NBC CNN or NBC Nightly News or
whatever it might be tonight they're not
going to see anything about these
hearings what they are going if they if
they get anything it'll be a little bit
of the AOC hey also you didn't believe
that the hearings were worth hearing at
all
on MSNBC here is Joe Scarborough and Jen
saki you like how jensaki has somehow
made a return to this show how did this
happen I thought we buried her bones
like Freddy Krueger you know if you bury
the bones they don't come back
but anyway she's still here uh and
here's their analysis of what happened
analysis please
it seems never
produce the punch they expect
and to go back to Mike markle's earlier
point I mean this is like a word salad
of right wing craziness right I mean and
if you are just a normal person 80 of
the country by the way that is not on
Twitter and you're hearing things like
Durham woke mobs many of the sentences
in Sarah Huckabee Sanders's speech the
other night you you tune in and you
think I have no idea what you're talking
about I I am I have to go buy eggs My
Health Care is too expensive my
prescription drugs are too expensive I'm
not sure about gas it seems down but I
don't want it to go up and it just feels
very far away so in a strange way the
this Republican strategy right now has
made them seem like this like right wing
Elite society that is not connected with
what is actually happening in the
country and she is just awful I'm gonna
have to rearrange my list of awful
people she just moved up a couple
notches because Corrine jump here we do
so much on her she had kind of jumped
her but if she's back if saki is in back
baby I'm moving her up the thing like
she's she's no one's beating Joy Reed
but she might be in Sunny Hosten level
at this point we're gonna have to get
the whole chart out uh the thing is so
many women of The View on that thing
maybe it's not fair you get you got your
Ayanna in here anyway
um
it's interesting because Jan saki is
seemingly upset that people are not
happy with prices of eggs and gas prices
and the price of Health Care uh who
remind me guys who's the president of
the United States what's his name again
Joseph R Biden and who worked for him a
few Jen Saki these people are such epic
clowns and also that Joe Scarborough is
saying these things never pack the punch
they want how much more of a punch do
you want than a member of Congress
saying I have evidence that you this
giant tech company were censoring me
before an election and I have evidence
from the company itself and we know that
government agents were working with the
company to do it there was collusion
with the FBI how is that not packing a
punch what he means by that is I'm going
to ignore the important things so I can
put on this hack sake to babble about
some irrelevant
[Music]
foreign